so that puts sorry come i getcha it's
Christmas isn't it it we do the annual
Christmas special
yeah I mean its annual in this is the
second year that we're doing it I don't
know company's annual okay it's happened
it's happening twice it's the second
time that I'm on two or three when it's
Christmas
oh happy I think we birthday was it
wasn't Christmas when you started last
year sure a second Christmas that I'm on
two or three okay and what we did last
year is we got a bit ambitious and we
did the 12 days of Christmas like we did
12 mini episodes 12 bits of content so
we changed around this time and what we
decide to do is do the world cup of
features that were that were released
all that went into chrome this year so
we did 12 last time yeah and we're gonna
do 32 this time great right we're gonna
find out which one the best is the best
feature of 2018 yes arbitrarily just
decided each feature will have its own
ten minute video
yes exactly no no no we're gonna try it
gonna try and keep it snappy oh and one
of the things it's gonna be really
annoying for people is that my jumper
has bells on it's very Christmasy sound
but I'm also sweating horribly in this
jumper and when I do that it's just
wafting into my places I'm Holly
polyester isn't it yes it is a Primark
special actually quite like this right
let's dig in well keep it short let's
let's go the first feature that I want
to talk about is display contents okay
and it's like the title slide but just
you know with them CSS wrapped around it
is this white and and this is this is
how it works what it essentially means
is the containing element pretend it's
not there in terms of layout so if
you've got a flex box mm-hm and then
inside it you've got an element that has
display contents and that has three
children inside it it will act as if you
know that wrapper element isn't there
they're all part of the flexible I don't
have a CSS selector still respect that
absolutely I think element yes that's
where the where the good stuff comes in
because you can write you can basic in
capital a the elements and
style them differently yeah but in terms
of layout they just bubble up yes so you
might want an element there for
semantics but you want the children to
be part of a flexbox or a grid this is
this is how you do it
all right so facing off against that
feature ah is in the future that I want
to talk about and it is reporting
observer all right okay reporting
observer I'm trying to remember if a hat
I have a code sample of us so reporting
observer
it looks like many of the other
observers that we have it beta gives you
a report for any kind of deprecated API
that you're using or for interventions
that you have triggered okay so this is
like when we block document rights you
would get an entry in the reporting
server describing to you that you have a
report or type intervention you will get
like the description and where in your
sauce get triggered YK triggered like a
lot of detail and then you can decide to
Center your analytics or do something
with it
excellent so is it just all of them by
defaults is that right or is there
anything just look like this much
configuration you know yes I know that's
nothing it'll is just whenever you use a
deprecated API or your intervention you
won't get a report in here all right I
said all right okay so let's what will
face these off against each other then
and I've been developing I say
developing I went to a website that
offers this feature already shalash calm
yes and I've set it all up like it deals
well yeah I did a lot of coffee and
pasting so let's let's talk about these
two then you have any initial feelings
no I
so they reporting observers probably
incredibly useful but only for sites
that actually you know go to production
and actually work for a business because
on my hobby besides my little side
projects I'm not gonna care so this play
Collins seems more useful to me as a
developer to a wider set of developers
maybe
yeah reporting observe is going to be
more useful to like big big companies
and these things don't even become it's
just businesses right Joe I am going to
agree with you all right we're gonna
declare display contents the winner yes
first round of the Christmas 2018 2:03
World Cup of what features
that's good I I imagined you regretted
starting that service as you went
through it so we now see in the next
bracket we will face it off against
something something else something else
which is totally not on screen right now
on scale is there so that is what I'm
going to talk about I'm going to talk
about scroll snap mmm Scrolls never they
got one yep so it looks like this and
here we go
I it's a great feature I really dislike
how we did it in CSS it's oh I'm an OG
this like I find it really hard to have
an intuition for it like I have to look
it up and see what X mandatory like what
does it mandatory about this you know
and then scroll snap a line honey like I
get it like I once I've read it
understand why we need all these options
but in terms of the choice of words it
feels it feels alien a little bit but
that's fine it's a good feature to have
it's an important figure it's not it is
a high-level feature let's actually demo
what it does so you can see here the
element is always sort of appearing in
the middle even if I try to make it not
do that and this is essentially what so
this is like the standard gallery
example right then your carousel where
you like you want a really Center on the
it's a big element so it handles that as
well I imagine it would be useful for
like on Twitter where you have like a
list but you want to swipe horizontally
onto a different kind of lists and
panels yeah that's a very common native
design layout I think and what it was
always hard to do it so let's bring to
that yeah it's pretty cool so facing off
I already forgot what was on the bracket
but Oh site selection and that's not
cool because that's literally it doesn't
affect how you write code really at all
this is security feature more for the
nth develop end user of browsers right
and now you can actually correct it
because you know more about site
escalation than I do but I know like you
don't write code differently except
maybe an HTTP header that you add to up
into it even stronger site isolation but
that's all that it really changes but it
is a good or really important security
feature and yet there's our it is our
tool against specter not down yes
exactly the idea of every separate site
should live in its own process it's
something that kind of happened in
Chrome
but it didn't quite happen with iframes
yeah you'd end up with multiple sites in
this and as a second mark because of
this we now have out of precise rhymes
or OOP it's okay right like a site
product and uh lives are actually in a
way a performance primitive because it
blocks iframe some effect in performance
of the top-level site absolutely they
can actually abuse that built little
performance containers and run multiple
things Avella of affecting the top-level
side as long as all your browsers to it
which yes which I don't well but they
are going to then what this is this is
interesting that this is not just a
chrome thing it's a Chrome has shown
that this is the right thing to do yeah
it's accurate
the only sensible thing to do in a
meltdown inspect the world exactly
exactly
well this is this is a hard choice I
mean we have to kinda fight what we're
looking for the best feature best
developer feature so it's actually two
really good features yeah because so
we're talking about a CSS feature that
people have wanted for for ages yeah
it's a really nice high level feature
with you know great performance all that
and we're facing it off against what is
saving people from being hacked losing
no data yeah I'm gonna go withdraw so
net points are you yes but that's
because I'm I feel like this is you know
a web development show and I kind of
like it's what developers will care
about and because it like it doesn't
affect development pretty much at all so
isolation it's just it's it's we need it
it's important but it's just something
that we need in the browser this nothing
in developer can do yes can enhance so
it's not really developer facing feature
so we could maybe like disqualify it on
those grounds pretty much agreed look at
that we have the first second around
face off exactly okay so we've got here
display context versus easy one honestly
really yeah I'm um I like display
contents but it's not that exciting
I don't need it that often scroll snaps
however I've wanted display contents
quite a bit and I feel like I've
sometimes broken HTML semantics because
it wasn't there because I couldn't put
the correct wrapper around something
because I wanted it to be in the Flex
okay I guess I'm I have a very low for
Hilton Bridge breaking semantic markup
on which school stuff is quite snazzy
isn't it innocent
now it looks fancy it looks fancy fruit
um yeah yeah all right okay I'm putting
scroll snap through this is this is a
decision being made there we go
will it update this is like a little
mini kit oh there we go yeah it's lovely
all right all right so we're done back
good time my turn I would like to talk
about named workers this is a big Here I
am show me this intact strapped in it's
a worker with a name yeah who could have
predicted this happening what does this
name do nothing no no it does do things
it will improve things like stack traces
it will improve things like dev tools if
you especially tuple instances of the
same URL it's a way to differentiate
them alright that's it oh cool I think
maybe what do we pitch in it against it
payment handler rights disclaimer I
literally had not looked into a payment
request and payment tender which are
interacting with each other and this is
not my Terry this is a G in a G would
know all of us will get super excited s
our colleague a G and I don't I have
never done paint like never written a
store on the web or maintained one or
had my living depend on it so I'm
guessing many people are excited but I
actually didn't get it to work either
way so here's roughly how it works and
it might be wrong a little bit okay okay
so you can do payment requests on the
web request a payment and then the
browser basically intervenes like hey
I'm gonna do like a very trusted you I
do you don't write but the browser
actually has built in and you can select
your credit cards or pay with Google or
with Apple pay yes all these things but
what if I wanna pay with so most totally
legit Bank I don't really I do because
it's totally legit okay excellent
yeah and that is what payments handler
allow you to do like you can now write
your own payment handler and basically
hook into this machinery in the browser
so this is rather than allowing PayPal
to do this we don't pay policy
- already built into most browsers for
example but this would allow the more
niche sites maybe some Bitcoin sites or
cryptocurrencies - you know do these
kind of payments and the way it works is
that basically you take the service
worker and you register a payment
Handler and you said your your domain
and your clear name and your method and
look what you what the difference
between the first key and the method
name is but that's it's code from more
or less the the guide and then you have
a new payment request handler right and
basically you're doing here and all the
samples I've seen you do a very long
running and respond with handler where
you launch in the window and guide the
users for your own payment flow and then
your resolve the promising anything
yep the person has paid and now the
other side cannot conclude this of you I
yeah so this is obviously super
hand-wavy because I didn't fully
understand it in the cushaw tenant I try
to read everything up but this is kind
of like a big step towards you know
making all of these payment if it was
more open when the weapon everybody can
you know hook into that fair enough
let's have a look at the board for this
now what we're doing here is we're
facing off payment handlers which is
really brings the web up to par with
what native can you prima and obviously
payments are a huge part of the web
we're facing that off against workers
with a named payment hundred let's still
because let's be honest the named
workers are okay I mean we have to
stress here that we're not like
diminishing any features that people
worked on these are all important things
that it's great to have all of these in
the platform they became part of the
platform for a reason but I just think
payment handlers a bit bigger so many
features are bigger than others and
that's okay excellent payment endless
has won this round yep so let's see
stuff what will be pitched against and
run to now if you know it's something
different is a nice background is a nice
background because I want to talk about
chronic gradients like a Konak yes it is
it is one of those I don't know is conic
I don't know who Nick I mean under I
didn't you know I'm from the north I
can't speak a great ok
this is I mean the syntax is probably
well known by everyone because everybody
wanted to have this feature for I don't
know how many decades
yes now it's finally ship now we have
custom paint but it could have
implemented ourselves now it's shipped
in Chrome cool yep yep literally
beautiful and I'm pitching against a v1
decoding Oh triangle triangle one decode
I thought we might I thought I'd give it
a fancy font because I thought it would
be mostly but this is I guess a corner
case where it kind of unreadable not
very nice no it's not okay so anyone is
a upcoming being work on I think almost
stable at this point video codec that is
completely free and open anybody can use
it no royalties and it is extremely
impressive in how efficient it is yes um
and so chrome now has support for it and
it's and it's all open source as well
green apple everything that's a
committee around it and everything that
said I think so chrome does supported
but obviously now needs hardware to
decode it faster right but most Harper
doesn't have because it's just been
standardized so it's not been put into
hardware and because of the complexity
it's actually quite yet it's difficult
well it with like gpgpu like use the GPU
decoded IC but I don't I don't know how
that works that is it's not my territory
I am quite excited the format um but I
haven't played with much because it's
just so new alright well thanks for
doing some research you're gonna throw
that back at me in some of the future
things no I think this is quite a it's
another tough one because we're once
again facing off quite a high level
feature that developers have been
wanting for ages with a huge leap
forward in on the open standards but but
in video technology yeah so might i post
me i'm gonna side with
chorionic gradients core ingredients um
I think people gonna use it more formal
adoption is always a hassle it's always
sort of like you just want to drop it
straight up short and there's detect if
your browser supports and shipped that
great but for me as a developer it's
cool but then it's gonna take probably
ages again for browsers to adopt it make
what P was
open as well and it took such a long
time for other browsers to adopt another
one is more detailed and more nuances to
the story but on I believe it when I see
it it's my stance on a v1 while Kona
gradients are something that I use would
have used a lot of websites I think
that's right I think once a v1 lines I
mean when I do video stuff on the web I
tend to just dump it on YouTube awesome
yeah give me heard some a similar
service yeah I don't have a lot of
contact with the codecs so I think what
is more what I would encounter more is
connect gradients so let's put that
through okey dokey right there guys
thanks for pushing the button no problem
no problem
let's take a light shove me into the the
thematic matter oh you yes exactly
oh we've got a couple of rounds oh we're
rippling up so we're now facing off
payment handle it with a ah that feels
so unfair radiance that feels really
unfair to be like payment Hannah seems
like really hard and long-standing
standards work and it's one of those
things that is going to like it's so
many things leaving the web because
payments is harder on the web than isn't
native and this brings them in that
scent it's so crucial for the web to
survive to have these kind of things
there
on the other hand no one's made money
from connect gradients no more excited
and you know I I am going to agree if
you using the consistent logic of what
we did before payment handler is
something that a few web developers are
going to use yeah in that case it's
actually the even more in each version
of payment handless it's not even
payment request there is good points
payment handless right right oh so we're
gonna go with right Connie Gradius right
I'm gonna you know press the button for
Connie
Koenig I'm pretty sure it's Connick but
Connick gradients and Jen's oh we end up
with two CSS features in the next round
and we can face these two off as well so
I I'm gonna give it two Scrolls now I
just think I grain to be used straight
up agree if it's visual like Konak
radians we can you could usually solve
with an SVG background image there's
many work on to the justice official use
canvas if yes as paint as many things
girls nap it's always has been main
thread bounds and weird ugly JavaScript
you have to do all the velocity and
six implementation that the operating
system usually already has it is such a
big tool for web developers sold right
yes
so that puts scroll snap into these
semi-finals interesting so I think I
think we should stop there yeah and keep
the rest for the next episode another
episode payments is something that a few
well talked about with you or your
connect gradients is something payment
handler is thank you for speaking
English give it a try that again
I reckon welcome back to the 28 th EP 2
or 3 world cup of web features so in the
previous episode we we looked at eight
features and we whittled them down to
our favorite like one of them off those
eight features yeah of those eight
features and if you haven't seen that
video then you should yeah this will
maybe make no sense and if you haven't
seen it so yeah it was scroll snap yeah
was our favorite one we don't either
what who were all snap one against but
no but we're gonna take a look at the
next feature and I would like to talk
about async clip board probably does all
it says on the tin there is well do you
remember clip board remember doing this
an exit command that is some API
designed straight of a hell yes yes it
is
and you would have to if you want to
copy some text you would have to create
an input element because that's where
you could do the Foley and selecting
properly it allows we're contending
setting Marcos in the Dom text selection
Marcos which gets even worse which is
horrible
if you copy you've changed focus you've
changed selection this is very
destructive things and supporting a fee
then you had like your fallback flash
plugin until last support yeah horrible
so this is it's a sink so it's for large
content it's less like you can be
blocking on the main thread which is
great but I think the main sell here is
isn't that nice it's so nice isn't that
nice and I'm guessing there is not just
right text and read text but there's
also going to be files and images
because here's screenshots on many
operations and just go onto the
clipboard first
yes potentially in many formats so that
bit is not there yet yeah that's
something that's but it's just text for
now so winning already but absolutely
absolutely winning so that brings us on
to the next one which is typed om that's
a hook that's typed on that's a good
eenie bit so it's actually one of the
the lower almost less exciting API so
you're really selling it yeah that it's
very necessary that to make all the
other ones happen and it's actually
interesting a huge pain point I think of
many developers because okay it gives
types to CSS stylings okay so you might
know get computer cells or just the dot
style property on an element yeah and
there is now the typed versions which
are either element computer style map or
the attributes tile map okay and so now
we have a style map so what does it
actually mean a style map basically has
getters and gives you separate number
values and their units so now you don't
need to do a string concatenation and
like somewhere it's splitting or all
these different things to figure out
what is the actual numeric value much
easier to do math with which is
sometimes have to do or just analyze
them and you know figure certain things
before you I really like what they've
done here so you got units px which is
nice and short it's it's what you write
in CSS now you have that and then here
we have percent really out I don't
remember why but there was a reason it
was a reason okay that's good that's
good it actually goes further than that
because you can also create these types
this way so you can you now have X and
basically a small part of the CSS POSIX
post and that you can just put in the
string and it gives you back that kind
of typing you can create them yourselves
and then set them this way but even more
excitingly you have add and subtract on
these you can actually do math oh so
you're the same way the calc works yes
so this actually if it's the same type
the same unit length it will just call s
if you have different like here I'm
adding five percent to ten pixels it
will actually give you a proper
arithmetic tree so you can do all these
analysis or like Rio
all this Asian sometimes want to do
without having to re-implement a CSS
parser okay and I'm I'm feeling that I
might know what his one may be here
let's go back to the truth I don't
remember to talk about oh yeah oh it's
so exciting and you can't remember it
even 30 seconds later I just I think
that clip what is good yeah
it's it's not that often that you need
type 2 M directly you need them for a
lot of the DNA api's and if you need
type to him it is so huge to have it yes
and then again you don't need clip on
that often as well I guess unless in
certain circumstances so and yeah I'm
gonna eat a ton okay okay I agree so
acing clipboard it's a big improvement
to what we had it's just a lot going on
in type Toa this is no it feels like it
wins just for being a bigger feature
it's definitely something I would have
loved in the past like even you have
small parts of that yeah I love when I
get excited and ever it's jingling and
there were some experiments where they
had like animation heavy sights and they
basically rewrote them with type term
and actually got eighty percent faster
it's a big number that's the best big
number I I'm gonna put it through that
goes for it right next you know steady
on because the next feature is update
via cash okay yeah so this is a
serviceworker feature I'm not surprised
what happens we had three antis problem
where we were checking for updates on
the serviceworker using the HTTP cache
and who has things normally happen
everywhere for everything I was at cash
back at Ashley the HTTP cache but we
would always time things out after 24
hours you know if it was over 24 hours
old we would go to network regardless of
what was yeah cash no me the caching
headers a lot developers still had a lot
of issues with that because they didn't
have control over their headers for like
one particular javascript file like the
serviceworker yeah
good up pages what I think is a good
example we don't have control or we had
us exactly exactly yeah they have a
default cache of like 10 minutes or
something random yeah so we introduced
update via cache where you can tell the
serviceworker what to go to the HP
cash for what to ignore so for the sauce
you got you tell the browser whether to
respect the HTTP cache for the
serviceworker files specifically yes I
guess so you go to every cache all which
was the old default and it's not the
default anymore
there's imports which is saying don't go
to the cache for the main serviceworker
file but anything it's imports you can
go to the that's cool that's the new
default or you can say ignore the cash
for everything right that's that's my
future my feature I what was my feature
desktop pwace so I have local temples
because it's once again something that
doesn't really change the way your write
code or gives you any nuclear bliss but
it's basically the whole install to home
screen but on desktop make it its own
window make it its own button in the
launch or on the Start menu or whatever
you have nowadays yeah um and we etch
has a kind that with allowing you to
submit PWA to the store yeah they were
ahead of everyone and do but you still
couldn't just install something from
edge to your desktop that wasn't
possible yet to submit it to the store I
think I'd approved I think oh and I got
in there so now with Chrome on Chrome OS
and on Windows and I think on Mac behind
the flag yeah that's gonna fire em you
can let it open the menu and say install
this and then it gets into the launcher
with its own window its own I can it's
on a command tap spot and all these
things so becoming a proper application
on your desktop it's kind of replacing
electron for a lot of sample simpler
cases hopefully hopefully okay so this
is is it a difficult one because what
when I talk about update via cash the
big news there is that we change the
default yeah not a new feature it's a
change
yeah mmm shaky ground desktop pwace it's
not developer facing feature well it
kind of is because it's something you
can talk about my app camión desktop
it's not even on all operating systems
yeah it's a week round if two things are
actually we've been really well received
I think up it fair cache solves oh
really so I was gonna say like I think
desktop pwace it's it's such a major
thing it's something that
it's moving the web into the native
space I guess I think I guess you're
actually right it just doesn't feel as a
real to me yet because there's no direct
api's for it yeah let's not install
planet I think on desktop it doesn't
prompt you to do it you need to set up
and so have a button for it I'm fine
with lying that's it that's what people
do race through okay well I find in
these sort of things like I feel that
you've done me a favor by siding with me
which is weird because it's against the
serviceworker feature you set yourself
up mate I did didn't I I worried I now
owe you one maybe in a lay around oh oh
yes I'll call in that favor when I need
it okay so that moves desktop he drove
us into the next round into round 2
which so type 2 and desktop here to be
waste I've done I'm really talking about
this yeah actually the more I think
about you well you know Titan because it
doesn't allow me to write better code
like that sort of PWS don't give me
necessary new capabilities I'm not I
don't make your life easier as a web
developer yeah they might make it easier
to like get more work because you're
because you're able to do things that
are more like native apps and also I
feel like lots of other features are
still missing to make most of the things
I do want to have in a separate app
actually possible in a web app file
access that's one of the main things
that comes to mind so many apps I would
like to have as a proper app are still
not possible on the web so the the
exception would be like yeah what's up
web can I can install I guess I'm also
quite not too sad about that being a tab
yeah I feel like a lot of people are
going to be screaming at the screen
right now I mean it is YouTube after all
go nuts in the comments okay so next up
as you may have seen on the screen there
but I usually find this really difficult
to read because I kind of got bitmap
rear end minute map pre-render or a pre
renderer okay it's bitmap pre-render
bitna pre renderer yeah check it out
look at this I can test bitmap renderer
here
I'm now wondering if I
I think it's book about Bren rock bitmap
pre renderer because I think it is
bitmap render and I fit my pre-race okay
yes see it's difficult to read okay so
the jingles are they get angry as well
its bitmap renderer of course if it my
friend wrote right here it is create a
canvas but get context Oh
also know get get context type it's a
new context type and what you can do
with this is you can you create an image
bitmap we should existing feature mmm
good feature nothing to do with this you
can transfer it onto the canvas so just
a fast path for basic canvas draw image
yeah that's pretty cool it's like like
blitek I'm guessing with this super fast
another hood where there's like all the
other layers are skipped it's a little
bit faster it is very efficient on
memory because this is a this is
transfer yeah like this image object is
now oh yeah it's been transferred in the
same way as if you were crossing over to
occur it's so d the image the data
buffer is no neutered as it's called use
it exactly great and and and then game
engines are gonna be happy all right
yeah going up against the bitmap
pre-render over rather yeah is web locks
I have many fields both good and bad
about web logs let's take a look at the
at the API basically um sometimes you
have a resource it might be shared
between multiple workers or even
multiple tabs of your web app yes via
IDB or something else has shared across
your origin the serviceworker for
example yes and and so you have some
code and it does some thing you don't
need to lock and we need a lock you
request a lock by a name it's just a
string name and then an async function
will get invoked with a lock once you
have that lock and then you run your
code because that might not be
straightaway because something else you
go look right and then once that acing
for interest and running the lock will
be released and you can continue
normally and there is also a concept of
shared locks and exclusive locks shared
locks if you request a shared lock and
you can get it if there's only other
shared locks right ok an exclusive one
you have to wait until there's no other
locks you like an exclusive lock because
shared locks are fine if lots of things
are reading for something
so aggressive lock is for writing I like
that when we shared an exclusive though
because there's multiple patterns not
just to read write pattern okay right so
and because sometimes you might be
reading and writing but on and disjoined
parts of an array okay so that what I
saw it work and yes okay so yes so this
is something that lots of people have
requested I think the more thing I think
it's actually necessary I think there's
also to be done without this insuk using
the actor pattern where you have one
designated threads but that's a
different story
yeah it was why have you done
underscores this is not very because I
copy pasted from Indian good excuse a
good way out of it cuz I dislike that in
JavaScript it's not like any of our
api's right I mean it feels to me like
web blocks is just a more it probably
all that has on average more use cases
then the bitmap ran right hey butBut
Brenner it's kind of niche for probably
game engines probably some image
processing it's good if you've got an
off-screen canvas and you want to
transfer but yeah let's say we put web
block that's really clear web blocks the
winner of rank number seven round number
seven okay all right so web blocks is
through to the next round one we what
are we going to look at now I want to
talk about reach reach ' okay it's the
font again this is feature policy lots
of buzz around future policies at CES
yes there was so here's basically how it
works this is a header and you serve
this on your page and it's essentially
it's like CSP CSP for fugitives exactly
so here I'm saying this page may not use
to your location it's so you're
declining yourself access to the
geolocation API oh just good because it
means what somebody evil injects
JavaScript code they can't do these
things exactly exactly and you can also
specify it for an iframe so you're
saying this iframe may not use
geolocation and there's lots of great
assignments I would presume yes exactly
yeah you probably want to put quite a
lot of this and if you really want to
restrict what if you've got me and
there's a massive set of future policy
so I'd like for like if your images are
too big for this so that one yes that is
one but that's
Spira metal one that's not released the
ones that are released is autoplay
camera document.domain stopping that
which I quite like because that might
come with performers benefits later in
that okay
eme full screen geo location obviously
microphone MIDI payments stuff VR a
written speaker here can't remember what
that is synchronous xhr as well so i
think yeah that's all good stuff
absolutely because yeah that's some of
you definitely want to stop and i hear a
plan future is like if you opt out and
of a certain subset of features you
actually get there could be the option
to enable a faster path in the browser
because if you can opt out of legacy
stuff the project oh don't need the
legacy stuff i can be faster like the
enable certain optimizations potentially
in the future yes absolutely absolutely
right nope you got coming against it
seeing as paint api oh yeah I want four
people do my CD s talk oh yeah but maybe
that's it's a 50 minute video if you
want to see the unedited version yeah
and wrong for you yeah version of see
the paint API basically it allows you to
define your own paint routine whenever
CSS expects an image so just before the
skwerkel is is the point where your talk
failed it's either yes we had a
catastrophic laptop meltdown i'd it and
you've yet you've brought it up here yes
i I wanted to absorb the squirrel from
the curse that is crushing it sorry I
interrupted yes so skwerkel is basically
a square it is mathematically closer to
a circle then and it's a way to paint a
rectangle with rounded corners but it
looks a bit more natural than how
rounded corners for example and and
browsers can do that you have Auto
radius and if you don't like how it
looks then you're kind of screwed and
now with Cesar's paint you can basically
hook into the actual paint part of the
rendering pipeline and define your own
paint routine so here I basically load a
module which is a JavaScript file into
the paint worklets and I username and
then in that file I can define the paint
routine everybody get the same context
like a canvas right and just refine what
what I'm gonna draw and you get the
geometry which is going to be telling
you stuff like how big is the element
and the properties were other styles on
this element and you can like
incorporate all of those in your jaw
code and the good thing is that in the
very near future this code is gonna run
off the main thread basically not
costume une main thread budgets that
probably only have like 60 milliseconds
per frame okay because previously if you
use canvas it could end up costing your
friend but is it on main for it now
currently it is okay okay there's a
furniture of worklets in all three needs
that they're my Gretel so whenever we
think it's feasible to move it to
different thread we can we can without
you having to change your code okay okay
right so this allows you to reduce the
Dom and stuff right it's so I guess we
should have a think about those features
this is a tough one is it I think was I
was gonna go straight in with CSS pain
yes I lean towards feature policy but
it's not to me to be honest that's
mostly because of the projected future
and not of what it gives you right now
because right now it's mostly
development debugging slash develop and
feature like opting out of features but
I have the hope that it is our way out
of supporting legacy stuff for long
amounts of time
well document.domain that's yeah that's
one of those and I think if future
policy today like it said you put this
combination of things in this stuff is
gonna be twice as fast yeah
then I think I would be putting it
through yeah but that's not what it is
today the range of things that CSS pay a
API sort of opens up it feels like the
I'm more excited about do my you know
it's a deal like it's more excited about
what it can do today flutter is using it
as well for their web port for example
were they to publish a blog post about
to do all the the mask imaging in form
morphing and all these things is
actually pretty impressive the uses that
I didn't necessarily think of myself so
it's it's quite good so let's call it C
that's paint API I'm gonna put it for
free so now we have web locks versus
Caesars paint API the CSS paint API to
dy / features one of them many more use
cases in my opinion on average then the
other one which because is made that guy
like for me it would be suspended it was
more use cases to yeah it makes a lot of
new things possible but also makes of
all things much more efficient and
especially on low-end devices where
you're under memory constraint
it just gives you
makes more visual things possible it may
feels though gives the weapon more and
high-fidelity feel and it's more hyper
than you eyes I guess and it's the first
feature is really opening up CSS yeah I
can see there being more little micro
libraries released with weave CSS it's a
very extensible one's API in that you
are now hooking into the actual engine I
really like web locks I really do but I
think you're right I'm gonna put a CSS
paint API through to the next round and
that gives us another semi-finalists to
decide as well and now we have to decide
between typed om in CSS the Houdini API
versus Houdini API oh this is
unfortunate isn't it I mean it was gonna
happen at some point
yeah depends on how we judge them on
average the problems that I encounter
when building a web app paint API is
more useful than type to him and both of
them are currently as far as I know
pretty much chrome only time to M has a
lot of lower level use cases right like
if you were if you're trying to figure
out layout stuff this is going to become
handy even the map times I've written
little rubbish pauses just to take those
values and break them so that's where I
guess my experience differs because mean
the problems that type themselves I
encounter much less than the problems
that paint API source we should just do
that for 15 minutes and I extended cut
all right let's find so you would say
tap done
yeah you're leaning towards type done
let's go pay API it is I'm more
interested in the tooling that's gonna
be built around CSS paint if you yeah I
think it's um I'm hoping it will be
really tough one yeah I'm hoping there
will be like an ecosystem of
off-the-shelf modules with all the
effects like a ripple and like you know
all the things that you can potentially
build yeah I do think that's interesting
and it also means we can all say yeah
our first like semi-finalists we can
come up with so so and this this is - I
mean see let's say this is two good ones
you would hope
this later stage in the competition that
if this would be to good ones but it
definitely to CSS features once again I
see a pattern I think yeah that's
interesting um so this is a really tough
one actually I I would the amount of
times that I've wanted scroll snap and
I've ever had to implement it in
JavaScript and it's been horrible
yeah who's been laggy like it so those
things are moving it's fast because
you're on the compositor but that
initial picking up the touch event is
starting to do the movement it often
involves like setting up a lot of layers
and compositor and then you do pretend
physics and you have to like do touch
and pointer events and mouse events and
yes there's a horrible moment where that
user swipes and then because it's
happened to go into your code you
physically it kind of is a bit of a
break before it there flings and then
you figure out this the the ramp up
curves and everything and no yeah I
agree scroll so I removes so much gold
and it's much more cross browser than
and see there's paint currently is that
is true actually scroll Snap is around
in Chrome and Safari but there is a sort
of older standard that's available and
all the other browsers oh okay yeah I'll
give it extra points because it is
something that you can use to very much
a day like in projects okay so our
finalists so we are 50% through we have
50 we have we have whittled down 16
features to one and we will do all of
that all over again with another 16
features I regret doing this already
well done yep how do we sign this off
see you next time it's not right so it's
video next on the other so on the flip
side on yeah soon next one subscribe
keep getting people back every day why
don't we do one episode per one of these
that have been everything much better
anyway so good at this we're so good see
you next time because I've already speak
faster
checkmarks I'm hearing up
[Music]
welcome back to the 203 2018 web
development feature world championship
contest 2018
yes yeah well we've been looking at web
features that have landed in chrome in
2018 because I went on to all of the new
in chrome posts in Britain about thanks
yes thank you Pete put them into a chart
here and we whittled 16 of them down to
one scroll snap that's the first
finalist yep that was a spoiler if you
haven't watched Super videos there's no
point watching them now it sucks to be
you
yeah well it sucks to be us because we
don't get the views but it's very enough
let's all the way back to the bottom all
the way back to the one we're going to
look at some more features and the first
one I want to talk about is web off
public key credential yes yes it is this
is part of the web off API the the
credential management stuff mm-hmm
which is Navy I have not really looked
at and I struggled to find like an
example of this I found a demo I
struggled to get the code out of it it
was really bad of me it was good and but
basically I can describe what the
future's going to do it was off ba what
what is ooh I super I have no idea what
that is well I'm gonna press it user
verifying that not an indicator is not
available that's not even what that okay
so using a verifying platform
Authenticator oh who knows it was
exciting though wasn't it if it's like
the negative things may be integrated
note this is the number things oh it's
now asking me to insert a security key
and it can be a Bluetooth one or a USB
one do you have one
no but I tried an earlier and it it will
give you the the key details like the
don't see the private parts about it it
gives you enough details so you can
authenticate that user later on okay so
I won't skip I could allow you to skip
all kinds of username slash passwords
see thingymajig so you just be like yes
put in your nubbie but
your nubby this is that it's like name
for those things is that I didn't really
not a brand name I don't know it sounds
hot
sounds like horrendous yes so you use
this with github being able to use it
either so convenient yeah back to
authenticate they don't use that I don't
know because I think for now was pretty
much Chrome only and had native support
for those yes that that is true so yes
that is public oh hi public web key
credential thing going up against what
public key credential thing is a toggle
attribute now this code sample the the
code that I've written for this it's
gonna blow you away okay here we go oh
that's it is it can I give a guess
yes go take a wild guess it's gonna
toggle that attribute isn't that it is
is it freely so I it it should I
classless toggle about Franchi words
right it also has the second boolean
parameter if you wanted to like toggle
and classless does but most of the time
use what a toggle clasp but this is
gonna be destructive though because if I
toggle it could have a value it could be
hidden equals something that's actually
true I didn't check that if you can pass
a value no I don't think you can do so
though cool that's it okay okay so we'll
go back to the brackets back to the back
to the brackets we've got target
attribute vs. now although I really
badly sold the public key could make you
so very excited about the prospect of
being able to to access two-factor
authentication tokens yeah it's awesome
yeah it's one of those things that
credentials payments are the things
where native apps are so far ahead yeah
all were and so having these sort of
things if I can't at some point write a
web app where people can authenticate
with a fingerprint or something and I
didn't have to like loop them through
authentication flow in my back-end but
just do it or client side winning
absolutely winning brilliant there we go
put it through okay let's let's look at
our next couple of features I would like
to talk about
off-screen canvas I know you excite
about that one we've already talked
about this haven't wait a little bit I
think we talked about Ana podcasts but
not yes a little bit and a meme about
the bitmap renderer is what the bitmap
a renderer or whatever days off-screen
canvas there you go it's like a canvas
but on screen but off screen and
therefore available a worker yeah
exactly sighting so you want to do
bitmap manipulation in the worker that's
great
you can also proxy it so you're doing
the computation in the worker your
because this has just got regular canvas
now mm you know to the WebGL but you can
also sort of transfer it so the I create
it on the main thread send it over to a
work and all the paint operation the
worker does magically appear on the way
around yes so you need your your main
thread your bit of your web page is
being updated by the workers and just
images I I do think is amazing going up
against this is the focus management API
now this is a very fancy word it was
mentioned in one of the new and chrome
blog posts with no explanation of where
what this API is no code sample no link
to the spec and I google it was very
hard to find it turns out it's the focus
method so you might remember you can
focus an element spin around for a while
it's very old so what's new about this
it takes a new options object now which
has exactly one option and that option
is prevent scroll so you can focus on
element without scrolling to it it it
almost feels like calling this the
scroll management API is a little it's
someone want to feel a JIT that's
someone making up their own job type of
like a master of development the focus
management API thank you very much so
it's this one option but is useful maybe
yeah sure if you wanted to send focus
for like accessibility reasons
especially and you didn't want it
messing around at the scroll position
I guess feels it there probably is use
case that's why cut standardized I
probably is use cases that's why it goes
standardized that's a good yeah good way
to think about it and I have not ruined
this myself and I it's yeah I feel like
I might have that if the the default
where the browser scroll might still be
obscured by like a position fixed
element I don't know I okay okay let's
stop talking so putting up against each
other its Austrian cows focus me if yeah
it's Oscar off-screen yeah there's not a
big discussion I mean just just because
it does so much more it's something that
well from a selfish point of view I
wanted it for for ages although there's
a negative point against it because we
try to use off-screen campus for squash
and there's a bug in chrome yeah it
forces a GPU switch if you have a laptop
with two GPUs an integrated one which is
you know not as powerful but does most
of the time and the discrete one for
like high power things for some reason
it forces a switch and that's super
janky yes if I could one second part in
the system because we were doing I was
doing some rotation of an image yeah and
it meant with very little code in a
worker it wouldn't I was actually
rotating big images so it's taking 300
millisecond yes even like with the power
of GPU and everything but that 300
milliseconds like moving that off the
main thread was just destroyed by the
one second of operating system jank and
you get with a GPU switch so that's a
shame so as a result of Afghan cameras
winning we now have to decide web off
public Creek credential API versus
offering canvas in canvas so what are we
talking about the current incarnation of
off-screen canvas or the projected
future of off-screen canvas so what do
you mean in terms of like exactly do we
incorporate this buck for example this
is you in the book is gonna get fixed
yeah because I think African canvas is
massive and yes I put me it would be
asking canvas I I think if we were
talking about web off as a whole not
just this yeah sort of part of web off I
think I'd be putting web or fruit but I
think probably I'm gonna put yeah you
might have a point I'm gonna agree if
you get off in canvas canvas all right
that goes through to the quality other
yeah no problem he said I don't build
apps a lot and half login maybe I should
change have to get some experience with
that big word quiz but we used Google
yeah ok fine fine let's look at the next
set of features I would like to talk to
you about sensors since Wallis
sensors specifically the generic sensor
API and that is these things which like
an umbrella term for we already had I
think gyroscopes for example for a long
time now yes it was like an event on the
yes and we're putting the document or
something a motion to change something
this brings them all together a lot of
sensors here there's a lot of sensors
and these are the ones that are in
chrome now but they all have a very
similar API in that you get like a
reading event out of them and then the
properties of the object has changed so
you'll get I think the event name really
bugs me reading yeah I didn't what
because when I first saw that I thought
that meant it has begun reading yeah I'm
in there or something but you probably
get an event every time there's a new I
think it's data set we available to read
I think I think it's it's not the verb
reading it's the noun it's a reading Oh
which I I would I would have to be like
a change event like we have I'm sure
there must be a reason why it's not a
change event and I think it's because
it's deep bounced maybe it's there now
it will be stick around the forever
so yeah you get all these things these
are actually really useful so that's
kind of cooler they're there it's
specially for like X are all these
things all of that stuff all right going
up against these sense horse is forgot
that you might want to do one again a
big a bit big and a big and a big and so
basically because you might have seen
him before
beginning this is a big int there's a
very big integer is a big integer yeah
because there's a magic n at the end
that's bigger than numbers I know like
12 and 89 so the only and Java could not
know so this is supposed to be a integer
and not just a float number and it can
be arbitrarily big like God will always
be saving every digit and you can have
multiplication and addition and all
these things now working on arbitrarily
large numbers vision mm-hmm there's a
modulo that's probably that's probably
integer division
I wouldn't hello okay integer integer
division right that's okay fun fun side
fact it is actually a new primitive pipe
Oh excellent which is there we don't get
those very often
no symbol it's been Maria we've got
symbol it's probably the most recent
edition before it was number object
function string big int okay excellent
right so let's let's talk about to them
too so
bigint now these both feel like things
that not many developers going to use I
have run into big integer concerns and
chose to ignore them because there was
no other way around it would you use big
int for a small intz we're here me up
realize this sounds stupid but I'm going
to try and rescue it in the next
sentence we're to use big in for small
imps if you did not want floats to
happen like for instance that you make
sure it's always integers I'm thinking
like if you're in one currency yeah yeah
like will only make we said the same
thing that boat that we didn't we think
we can possibly reshoot this and maybe
that maybe actually maybe and but also I
often with whenever you like talk about
certain I wonder if these work in Jason
actually like if you send them down from
the server if Jason Paris will actually
understand them nope probably not
chance there's no that much I know um
but there's often times I just don't
want to worry about if I'm gonna
overflow and whenever I build certain
libraries generating random uu IDs
instead of like distributing inch just
across an array and then doing
operations and I could just build one
UUID and then just sliced up that's many
use case where I see them as being
useful sense us are more niche to me
than big I'm gonna admit a bit still
pickers are probably kind of nation and
not that's the thing these are both
really niche not really I think those
are more nice ship except in exile and
yeah okay yeah okay yeah yeah okay yeah
okay
mostly because I can't make a decision
and I'll let you make the decision they
can go through taking this round
excellent
next up here we go so the life cycle API
we did a big we did a big effort on this
one we do it I don't even know how much
we talk about it again but it's it's
this especially sure code about it I
think yeah I think you're actually it
was a in a way it's just new events but
they're really useful yes it takes stuff
that mobile browsers already do
discarding tabs because they you know to
save memory it kind of wraps us back
around it
it also introduces this idea that page
will be frozen which means that it's not
running anymore but the memory for it
still exists so it can be resumed yeah
so this is if it's discarded as and it's
taken out a memory and the use of
revisits a tab the page is essentially
reloaded but you can detect that it's
something that all native platforms have
from like literally version one life
cycles on the first thing they build to
recycle views to figure out where they
go and the web didn't have it and now it
does so it's a massive step in actually
building something it behaves more like
an app and how you expect it you sold it
then I have let's see how you do on one
of your what do I have certain ease I
don't know about this and I actually
found it quite interesting so server
timings in enough themselves are looking
just a new header so it allows you to
put a word in there and say like this
request missed the cache for example you
can have multiple um server timings in a
header so for example at like this
request took 2.4 milliseconds to be
processed of CPU time well I guess it is
just random names you can give them your
own names they're just names for these
different timings so I said this one has
a flag set to true called missed cache
ok CPU server timing is set to 2.4 if I
wanted to I could even add a description
and these are sent along with a response
from the server so you can send your
server timings to the client and over
there you basically use the performance
docket entries by resource array which
were every reason you have requested on
your page you can now inspect and in
there you have so these every entry is a
resource and each entry has an array of
server timings and so in there you have
the MS cache flag you have the CPU thing
that I set up there what would you do if
this data probably sent to your
analytics to tie it to a user and be
like oh a user on this device had
problems but the show was already slow
and maybe correlate certain features
it's not it's mostly analytics your
server sends these things to the client
yeah so the client yes it sounds a bit
but the problem is that often when you
have load balancers they make decision
based on for example user user agent so
these timings might differ depending on
what the client is so you want to tie
these measurements to the client and
ideally to get timing that might emit
more
measurements on the client-side later on
right of course because you could take
the the client processing performance
stuff as well and tie that into one big
analytic that you sends maybe one user
has an extraordinary large music
collection and so all the clients have
become slow but there is no way to tie
these two timings together until now
until now
fair enough fair enough okay let's let's
discuss these ones then still an easy
one I think oh okay I was gonna saying
life cycle yeah okay okay and I think
and I know there's many data different
people there who get super excited
collecting more data and I'm excited and
statistics are great and everything but
for me as developer life cycle is just a
big hitter agreed I excited about the
sort of stuff we'll learn from server
timings I'm excited that hopefully
things that Google Analytics will make
that not something I have doing prevents
true it will just happen literally yeah
although I guess maybe if the some of
the server stuff I would have to do that
but that's that's not a big deal but yet
life cycle for me it just explains some
platform things which have been under
SPECT for so long yeah and to finally
have them is a big deal and now we need
to figure out bigint versus life cycle
API I'm gonna go yeah I'm agree it's not
a big discussion for me big end is great
and I love that we have it because all
the libraries were super big but again
its niche while life cycle is literally
at the app literally every ant won't
probably touch this API if you want to
do it right and to be able to especially
on mobile to be able to go back to a tab
and have a way to even though the page
is closed or the stage for restores
estate yeah absolutely and this means we
get to decide on next now we've analysts
let's that's rough this is this is a
tough one
this is a tough one off-screen canvas
versus lifecycle API I know politically
in terms of the overarching the story
arc of the web yeah it would be life
cycle for me personally the things that
I do on the web it would be off screen
canvas ok so this is the the the squoosh
use case which was like doing things
like rotate an image compressor we did
we finally built an image compressor but
doing things that rotation resize and
that without experiencing main thread
stuff
generating a new favicon all these
little things that you often want to do
yes and that's yeah if you're generating
a notification icon in a serviceworker
like out of here's the two people that
were part of this chat
yeah then write the icon for that I'd
like that I worry it's nitch but then so
here's the thing
life cycle shouldn't be niche everyone
should be doing it yes everyone should
enable let's have to come back to life
in the same state that it it was in it
actually acquires a big mentality shift
because right now nobody writes apps in
this way on the way if you do it with
the URL if all of your state is in the
URL you find I guess but but in a lot of
apps it's hard like if you think about
yeah um it just as simple to do this
you're in the process of writing it to
do you switch tabs it gets frozen or
discarded nobody persists that
half-written to do to the URL bar that's
true
oh so you want to go back and still have
your have written to do this there yeah
and you know rely on something checking
ID b10 page load which I don't get hope
does a good job of so if you require big
metal chips but so does moving work to a
worker and as I have found out it's very
hard to get developers to in the
mindsets I think both of them excessive
pain is and where can I get made I'm
working on it or am I'm gonna say I'm
gonna I think we agree that life cycle
is probably in overarching the more
important problem to solve let's let's
go with it I'm definitely willing to go
with that now we have life cycle I guys
or first second semi-finalists are first
second semi-finalists exactly that that
makes sense so yeah we're gonna leave
that there for this episode gonna find
our a second second semi-finalists in
under our winner actually yes really I
find a second finalists and while we're
there we may as well do the winner I'm
not ready for that
oh you want to say that as well I don't
know anything's gonna be linear we
really messed this one up we're gonna
get it right from now on I barely ever
only trim on one side are usually that
lifestyle choice
[Music]
welcome back to the AVP 203 world cup of
what features 2018 are you bringing the
enthusiasm yeah that's really good this
is the episode where we find out who
wins yes it is because everything in the
previous few episodes we figured out one
finalist did we reveal that now or
should we know you have my forgotten and
I want to keep it that way so I don't
incorporate it into my decision that's
good thinking we did in the last episode
to figure out the other semi-finalists
which is yeah it's like the page
lifecycle
yes correct why you just get the word
page it's part of the API name isn't it
I'm gonna try using that tactic of
arguments in in this next as well just
oh okay trim star trim and once again
the font is making it I'm here legible
it's like okay let me explain to me no
trim mmm gotcha remove them space let's
start an end trim left trim right deal I
thought that was already left and right
so I wanted if you type out a
non-standard oh but in pretty much all
browsers I think except edge okay sure
start to amend so go so here's that
question then though mmm does trim start
behave differently not in right or left
languages oh I was wondering that but
because there's no language applied to a
JavaScript environment yes in a web
environment but not in the JavaScript
environment which this is I'm pretty
sure there is absolutely no difference
so we're calling a trim start from NB
cuz we already have trim left to right
but it's not standard so and we have pad
start and patterned and it's basically
to make you okay sure yeah so that's it
and you know scanning my notes yes this
is now in everything except edge but it
has landed in chakra so it would it's
likely to be in the next version of edge
alright going up against that is import
dot meta or imported metas basic an
object where you have metadata about
module that you're currently in okay and
I think the only thing that's on there
right now is the URL property and as
more or less equivalent to what document
on current script dot source used to be
right the thing you can't use that is
because if you have the document dot
current script gives you the script tag
off the that's included in the document
yeah yeah that's currently running right
now the problem is has an import or that
JavaScript module can have an import and
so that doesn't have a script tag so
what is current script supposed to be so
it's giving you the URL of the current
script not not exactly super important
if you think about and if you wanna do
some path mangling for dynamic imports
or any kind of like module loader or
maybe just do relative path with
solution all these things but it so dir
name thing that you know okay kind of
thing so it's it's a simple feature but
it's actually quite quite powerful
useful all right so it feels like we had
two quite small simple features there
okay it's a nice change so it feels like
we could probably make a decision
reasonably quickly but then I so trim
start tremendous feeling you because we
already have it all so I barely ever
only trim on one side I usually trim all
the way I am going to vote for probably
the same reason to you import metal yeah
yes it's more of a feature it is a new
thing we're actually really painful once
you run into the problem that um it's
not important all browsers yeah you
cancel it but lawyers are but the import
of meta has not and if something is
really annoying sold there we go
important matter
let's introduce the next feature which
is this is a lot of letters reg X reg X
the see see the phone is terrible it's
like beg X beg ex named capture groups
yeah I know these ah I heard of them I
never actually to the syntax but it is
just this you you you know I find Rick X
to be right only yeah it's executable
line noise like it's yeah and once
you've written them it's absolutely
you're right and you go one two three
what is that I don't know
and you a second ago a now--don't but
being able to do this like name groups
like this and then so result groups you
get yeah stuff out
brilliant before that you only had a
numbered array and it would be
completely unclear exactly you're doing
and another place that would be unclear
is when you're using string dot replace
oh yeah you can use the group names
there as well so in this example I'm
changing it from being mm day to day
mafia and because month day year is
absolutely nonsensical and should not be
used agreed yes to people European there
we go we absolutely think that so yeah
on that next Wednesday okay we've been
proven to be non trustworthy when it
comes to breaking okay first dating it's
not what I meant
alright going up against Rick ixnay m--
captured groups yep
under that right um is relative time
format we're going well I mean the other
thing wasn't strictly to do with dates
but that we're still sticking we're
sticking in yeah in that territory this
is basically moments jazz on the
platform oh it's it's it's yeah we got
it so you can basically create a or time
format instance that is localized in
this case I'm using English because you
know we've been mostly speaking English
nuclear and German but I didn't okay
also we can mostly cut the paces and was
too lazy to actually generate a German
one yeah yeah you just pass in here's a
number here's the unit it will give you
that as a localized string and just
obviously many more options if you want
to have like an full breakdown or just
the highest absolutely only have like
four months three days and two hours ago
or if you want to just have one of them
if you want to have it more numeric or
spelled out as words all these options
are there but basically moment.js no
platform it's a big dependency that you
can hopefully ditch now well I I mean I
felt like it was going to be an easy one
but now I'm less sure I things like
moment.js
are one of the things that leads to
quite big bundle sizes because you end
up with these large libraries in for
especially if you like done free
shipping there like all the localization
still in there and breast so having that
just in the platform that feels like a
huge win the right thing is really
useful for the readability of like
but how often do you use for eggs I know
Jason lives off of red X yes
you mean colleague Jason Jason Miller
because it sounds like you're talking
about the web standard Oh Jason Jason
these are a guess it's like you knew
should not pass you're Jason with no
eggs turns out you can't parse languages
with rags no I mean I mean Jason Miller
who does all kinds of minification and
mini code me micro library magic and
it's often because reg X but I'm gonna
say the relative time for ya it's it's
one of the first bits of Intel that I am
really really happy with I'd say yeah
like that sort of it I found it it'd be
it's a well-designed API it seems yes I
think there's still some things that
could be even better but you know what
I'm gonna cut my losses here it's a good
idea yeah it's something that you could
legitimately replace moment with yeah
and look we have we have a new thing to
decide so import matter also time format
I'm gonna go over the time format
oh you're less sure I'm trying to
subjectively that I have run more often
into imported meta when writing stuff
letters into a batch of time format that
being said pretty much a lot of apps
need the right have time format many a
probably don't need import not matter so
in terms of the average developer I'm
gonna yeah I'm gonna type with you it's
the the bigger big hitter here though
yeah the winds for for the web by
reducing those model sizes feels bigger
that important many you could probably
work around in a lot of cases there's
probably like a babel plugins something
that does it very possibly very possibly
right okay yeah alright so we were you
got relative time formats
through to the next stage but now I want
to talk about resize observer I've I've
got a feeling this might go far in this
contest because I that's because I wrote
the article on it you did right yeah and
that's it's it's a really good article
as well and it's such a amazing feature
I think it's also quite simple it is
also it is also quite simple I would say
it's it's yeah you give it an element
and it will tell you when it changes
size yeah some of the complexities in
how it handles recursive changes like it
only only if it sort of things inside
the element that I change yeah but most
of the time that is something you
shouldn't be running into it but yeah
most you just say this is a resize event
for elements rather than just the window
absolutely yeah and and and that you can
build like element queries I think
they're called on top of this all these
things that's right that for me is a
selling point it's it's the element
containing a query stuff that
technically wanting for ages so okay has
to beat the resize observer I guess all
your clicks oh ok so another worklet the
work looks I can't go platform yes your
analyst so a little bit of catch-up
usually when you do audio you create an
audio context and then you can create
notes and connect them so in this case
I'm creating a track note from an audio
elements then I'm creating a game note
which allows you to adjust the gain how
much louder or quieter do I want this
audio to become right and a pen or do I
want it on the Left speaker the right
speaker somewhere in the middle okay and
then I connect these notes like it's
like a little data flow model
it's very soon as what you do in an
audio system where you're putting things
into each other like different print the
reason it's written this way is because
all of its running in a different thread
so although all this data mangling is
happening in a different event because
it's audio has to be usually super low
latency latency is one of the biggest
factors when you do audio work it's kind
of declarative yeah yeah and but then
people like well I kind of want to
manipulate the buffers myself I wanna
get an audio buffer and do some math
myself right and they were looking at
like do I do do we do events but events
are async by default so it gets really
hard with a real timeless and now
worklets are a primitive that actually
gives a solution because now I can do
your own node so this is the same code
but now there is a some node and the
some node is basically an audio clip
nodes and it takes a name and then in a
different file we that we loaded up here
I can extend them audio capacitor which
is the basic note and create my own one
and just in there I'll have access to my
inputs which is an array of buffers and
I can define what is in the outputs
right because because there is there are
ways to do this sort of processing on
the main thread I think is now
deprecated API because you run into all
of this the a sickness and the yeah all
the really harness problems in a slate
and see where the thread hops in as well
because audio is already a different
event but now you have to jump back to
main thread it gets unwieldy and the
worklets can just be migrated to
different thread run on the same thread
you can still maintain
in the same declarative API and allow
basically now to have DSP plugins on the
web all the effects that people do can
now just be ported to an audio worklets
that's nice
it's nice actually but but but it's not
resizes over though is it it's not it's
audio is still pretty it's just in each
use case like in general audio is
actually kind of frowned upon on the web
and then a person general like things to
start playing audio are bad that's true
and there is audio apps and those are
great and really impressed with how far
people get but the Audion use these
fairly small yeah the little bits of
audio stuff I've done on the web I've
really enjoyed I had loads of fun with
it
but it is I've only done it like once or
twice big quiz the first time was one of
them right yeah that actually might be
the only one and I did a little bit of
extra stuff after that bit was it was it
was much like a server it's just I mean
every browser like today please so I can
you know do that sort of stuff have the
you container queries the other thing
stop just attaching because what we do
right now is we attach a resize listen
to the window but that doesn't
necessarily mean that you know that's my
catch-all of case no I know them all it
gets on inclined rack and becomes a
performance foot gun it's so hard to do
right exactly exactly right so that goes
through to the next stage and now we are
coming on to the final two features that
we're going to talk about I going to
talk about cache mode on on fetch yes so
this is part of request objects because
it's part of a request object you're
always getting this this second
parameter of fetch as well yeah and what
you're essentially doing is is saying
how this request should go through the
cache if at all so with reload I'm
saying on the way out
ignore the cache mm-hmm but on the way
back it can go into the cache
oh you have control over both paths this
yes yes no no you say passes why not
it's Christmas some new words but you
just made up that's fine so yeah but
this is a good like if you know if you
know there's a more up-to-date version
but you but it's the user has has a one
in the cache that yes yes one in the
cache yeah
what's in this yes
so you can bypass the the cash Mesilla
basically no store would then be on the
way out it can hit the cash probably not
no store behaves as if the cash isn't
doesn't exist
okay so bypasses the cash both ways and
no cash yeah not that I'm reading this
off a piece of paper it will even if
there's if there's an item that is fresh
in the cash it bypasses it but it will
still do a revalidate potentionally cash
fresh in the cash like okay force cash
means if there's something like the
stuff undoing the cash busting thing
where we put like random Crary things
amongst other things but but with force
cash it means that you could take the
item into cash even if it's stale yeah
like max-age and only have cashed me and
also don't hit the network at all right
but well force cash will still hit the
network only if cashed will not
interesting that's it and lots of
control I like it yeah
only if cash it has to be same origin
that is the future all right going up
against that is class fields oh yeah
so it's oh I don't know about this song
it's it's pretty simple it's it's this
okay it's so so far which is one one so
it doesn't include the private no right
well basically it's built on top of it
so once this is landed in chrome the
private ones are the names are started
with a with a hash hash tag hash yes
those will only be accessible but from
within the function f from okay within
the class not from outside and this is
pretty much just sugar over I guess over
getters and set it getters but the
biggest beneficiary would for example be
custom elements because you have the
observed attributes feel that always has
to be aesthetic get a function and now
it could just be a prop aesthetic
attribute and it just looks nice and
it's easy to be what's going on what
about the instance ones that's so it's
that where do they happen in relation to
the constructor do you know I do not
know I'm assuming it runs before the
construction after the super constructor
but before your own constructor I think
that's what type script does so yeah
that would make sense yeah I think maybe
who knows maybe right okay so that means
away with the slides away with in with
the bracket
this this is it um so okay one of the
things that is pushing me towards the
cash mode is that it's actually
capability right well it causes like
yeah it clusters of sugar and it's also
sure good that I write a lot of
typescript these days yeah I just I
already have it yeah yeah I get it
I mean it lad that it's going to
javascript proper and I'm I'm more
excited about the private instance
properties true and and the things of
like old oh well they could be munched
in code minification yeah because
they're private yeah they're broke so
I'm more excited about that so I'd be
tempted to put cache mode free I haven't
run into the problem with the cache mode
very often I have to say where I wanted
to have control about how the fetch is
being handled that being said I think
it's a very because hope case is that
you've updated your serviceworker you
want to get the freshest version yeah
these things and you you're not in
control of go yeah it is I guess I
mostly happen when I was inside myself
but yeah I agree it's what I would say
is anything we pick now I'm gonna be
voting resize observer in the next
though both of these loose against
recess observer so what going I let you
pick put cache mode through I go it's an
actual capability I was missing more
class fields we had a workaround for
years it's been fine yes and absolutely
nice it's nice yes
so next bit we already said it I yeah
yeah you agree yeah I rattled through
these yeah I just think resize observer
like you have probably like stuff that
solves is is amazing yeah so it resize
observer the amount of stuff that you
can do with it yeah it's very versatile
it's all it solves just a such a
long-standing problem so now now we're
getting into the interesting bits
yeah so what would we go here relative
time format and resize observer still
wreath I suppose over her mean I oh I
agree if they agree the amount of times
that I've wanted resize observer in the
past it is loads yeah life is load yeah
yeah loads times to I would say so let's
put resizes over through to the next
round and we'll see where that
says here we go now we're getting that's
a rough one now yeah could have
predicted this the thing is this the
interesting there's a commonality here
that these both solve long-standing
problems yeah
the the tab discarding thing has existed
the since mobile and there's only now a
solution to it the resize observer you
could sort of equally say that this has
been a problem since mobile as well
because the whole responsive being
exactly came into it to be I'm gonna be
honest I feel like life cycle API is
more work around the ball than resize
observer yes because you could put stuff
in you have certain storage annular has
been there for a long time and you have
ITB you have local storage you have
means to persist state locally yes so
you could have done the right thing for
a long long time now in business just a
cherry on top for you well recess
observer you had to go to get bond and
client direct and other awful things I'm
pressing the button because I absolutely
agree with you and I think I now
remember this is our second finalist if
I remember correctly oh and I think I
remember now who are the finalists and
immunity of one CSS feature and one
JavaScript feature in our finance which
i think is amazing that is exciting oh
you're right yes I had forgotten about
it so so this it's kind of horrible that
with the amount of work that's gone into
these features and the the diversity of
the features that we now have to just
declare one the best arbitrary based on
just some loose opinions okay while
wearing a ridiculous jumper we should
feel like is that going in your ear
every time brilliant excellent actually
well it feels like we have to summarize
scroll snap again because no we I think
we should link back to the video you
just want another view yeah yeah why not
excellent what was the video if you
don't know what's called snap miss about
so we've got the hi I'm gonna show the
demo again why not is it it's a tab
we've got hero 9 now remember so this is
scroll snap this is isn't it great it's
it's not the best demo I've ever made
it's slightly underwhelming demo now
that I think about it but if this loses
then who
who made this demo is gonna feel pretty
terrible yeah so this is like having a
soar paged paginate system yeah within
your scrolling and you see that the
mobile UI is right where you have you
swipe between individual panels and you
just want them to lock into view yes I
don't want to reinvent the wheel would I
do just use a scroller and just let the
rest be handled by the operating system
yeah and it's nice it's in CSS so it's
super smooth it's bringing something
that is composited scrolling composite
it's growing it's a very native feeling
feature yeah because the browser and the
massage even the browser might yield to
the operating system hmm
so this isn't even something that
animation work look is going to solve
right because animation used to it
doesn't anymore yeah okay we used to
wanted to solve it but actually you
actually can in a way but it's quite a
key you can still if so use container
and then yeah like those girls networks
animation wrote with is your SK patch
okay and it's not as easy as it used to
be but honestly scroll snap covers the
95 percentile I would say all right so
and I think that's where my argument
lies both of these are there's also
funding problems currently powerful
tools big problems that have been around
for a long time so the in size observer
there's more types of UI that it solves
a problem for yeah like I can there are
definitely cases are you scroll snap
like the two cases we've mentioned
having a carousel which is the example
we're looking at and they having those
sort of like yeah paged you ie yeah
things which I have written that in
JavaScript it's incredibly hard and it's
still a bit janky and slow resize
observer
once that's in all browsers I feel like
I'm gonna have like five elements on the
page all doing react having no resizes
never doing different things applying
class names this is really difficult for
me my argument here is going to be the
amount of code that Scrolls snap allows
me to not write just outweighs what race
has observable awesome really that's a
really compelling argument actually I
like that because the did you if you
write scrolls up yourself in JavaScript
it's on the main thread you have to do
the physics things yeah and it's going
to be different from for example
androids they feel different when they
scroll and you either going
in uncanny valley or you have to have to
implementation aiming it both perfectly
yeah it's a lot of code it's very hard
to get right
for me it's gross snap and but then the
extensible web person within me is
looking at two features here one is a
high-level feature yeah I can't really
hook into and the other is very much a
primitive but that being said this is
that extensible web doesn't say them
should not be a high level features no
they should just be built in the they
should just be taken out of exposing low
levels first and then see the popular
patterns and then providing easy ways
for those and if we were talking about
an animation were clip where you can
control scroll position in this way
that feels like your next step this is a
big step that's the big asterisk in
about the animation worker story here
where you can't really control crook
scroll position anymore he used to but
that's been removed from the spec but
you can still achieve the same visual
effect yeah by skin Epping interview so
it is in escape hatch for this resize
observer we can you've got the window
resize listener you could infer stuff in
other ways I guess in it's difficult
code worst comes to worst you could have
a raft that's changing layout I mean
usually you know your breakpoints in
your CSS breakpoint so you could
actually avoid the get boning climate if
you do it's already now um it's
difficult to make modules like that
modules and components like that but
absolutely this settled i i i think i
agree i think scrolls not yeah it is
it's just how smoothly it does it and
although it's not something i'm going to
be necessarily using on every page as
you say it's it's a much bigger step in
the right direction from how we were
doing it today yeah versus resize
observer we should still a massive step
so with that our HTP two or three world
feature championship time capt thing
renderer is going to be scroll status
across an escrow snap in its course now
the emergence the the orange carrots i
was i was going to ask what they win and
i was thinking it was nothing because
our opinion is essentially meaningless
other than just what
we like what they literally gonna send
them the glittery carrot root of the
2008 glittery carrot award I like it we
should do it next year until next year
until next year
well done scroll snap I'm timing the
time because this is saying internal
server here let me try let me try this
again ok ok it's working we're backing